salve sono maria capobianchi il
direttore del laboratorio di virologia
dell'istituto nazionale malattie
infettive spallanzani di roma
fin da gennaio il laboratorio che io
dirigo si è occupato di mettere a punto
le strategie dei ostiche per
fronteggiare quella che all'inizio si
presentava come una minaccia ma che poi
si è rivelata una vera calamità in
quanto avete visto bene che è
interessata all'intero mondo oltre il
paese nostro facendo milioni di inferti
e centinaia di migliaia di morti
questo ha impegnato pesantemente il
laboratorio di virologia e fin
dall'inizio è stato necessario mettere
in campo inventiva e competenza per
poter fronteggiare un infezione nuova
tutte le impressioni nuove colgano il
mondo gli uomini gli scienziati i
laboratoristi e virologi impreparati
virtualmente la comunità internazionale
si occupa della risposta all'emergenza
in maniera sistematica ma purtroppo
qualsiasi emergenza ci coglie sempre con
un certo grado di impreparazione a dire
la verità in questi mesi nei quali si è
lavorato freneticamente e purtroppo ci
sono state tante infezioni e tante morti
qualcosa abbiamo imparato abbiamo fatto
molti progressi e questo perché la
comunità scientifica si è impegnata
moltissimo nella ottenere il virus e
virus è stato isolato il mio laboratorio
è stato uno dei primi in europa ad
isolarlo e reso possibile è trattato gli
strumenti diagnostici e indispensabili
per individuare i casi ho detto che
siamo diventati più bravi
è vero ma è un motivo di orgoglio ma è
anche naturale che purtroppo
l'esperienza vasi maturi nel corso
dell'esperienza della della pratica
quotidiana
noi oggi abbiamo un numero di edizioni
molto minore ma non solo abbiamo quel
numero di pazienti che hanno bisogno di
cure intensive molto ridotto rispetto a
quello che si è verificato nei primi
mesi dell'epidemia
e questo perché i medici il sistema
sanitario è diventata molto più
efficiente e capace di gestire
l'infezione i pazienti soprattutto i
pazienti fragili fin dalle prime fasi
cioè perfino la prima fase cioè quella
di individuare i pazienti e quindi di
attivare le strategie diagnostiche
poi a seguire l'esperienza dei clinici
nel gestire al bisogno di ossigenazione
e bisogno di supporto alla di supporto
di base alla patologia respiratoria ha
fatto sì che avessimo in questo momento
dei numeri molto molto incoraggianti a
questo naturalmente conseguito anche la
parola politica di lockdown di stata
quella attuata per impedire che la
trasmissione del virus a me disse
liberamente e quindi per limitare i
contagi quindi da una parte la
limitazione dei contagi dall'altra il
diventare il più capace di fare diagnosi
tempestiva e di gestire i casi ha
portato a quello che oggi possiamo
considerare un grande successo ma che
cosa ci aspetta nel futuro dobbiamo
dormire sugli allori
direi proprio di no perché adesso
comincia il punto più difficile e questo
è soprattutto per il laboratorio perché
laboratori sono impegnati nella parte di
sorveglianza o per identificare
tempestivamente le nuove infezioni che
potrebbero innescare dei nuovi focolai e
per fortuna adesso noi dobbiamo essere
fiduciosi che il cambiamento stagionale
le misure attuate e comportamentali
anche siano state capaci di limitare la
circolazione del virus ma non è detto
che come me si verifica per
moltissime altre infezioni che interessa
apparato respiratorio
l'infezione non si ripresenti dopo
l'estate
e questo ci deve non ci deve trovare
impreparati per cui adesso a sinista la
necessità di una accuratissima e
meticolosa ricerca dei nuovi casi oggi
che sono pochi e dobbiamo cercare meglio
le dobbiamo identificare per evitare e
si inneschino nuove date di trasmissione
e questo perché il mondo dovrebbe
imparare a essere sempre pronto dovrebbe
non attendere che si verifichi una nuova
galleria perché si riconosca la
necessità di essere pronti e di
continuare a studiare di fare
esercitazioni di mettere in campo tutta
quella che è la cosiddetta de paris in
questo caso noi abbiamo un epidemia con
un agente che è nuovo che probabilmente
ha infettato una buona fetta della
popolazione umana
ma come si verifica in altri casi in cui
eseguita preesistente in qualche modo
limita la circolazione del virus questo
non si può dire in quest'occasione in
quanto gli studi che stiamo cercando di
mettere appunto con gli strumenti che
abbiamo in questo caso lo strumento siro
logica ovverosia la ricerca degli
anticorpi in vari strati rappresentativi
della popolazione
quello che già si dice già che possiamo
vedere è che in realtà per quanto i
numeri siano stati i numeri importanti
la fetta di popolazione che fino adesso
è stata interessata è molto piccola
quindi una larghissima fetta della
popolazione è ancora suscettibile
all'infezione
e questo si rincontra anche con un altro
grande dilemma europeo sia quello che
già quelli che già a rotoli sezione se
la riprenderanno oppure sono protetti a
questo interrogativo mi oggi ancora non
possiamo rispondere
sarà una delle sfide alle quali dovremo
rispondere nel prossimo futuro perché
noi ancora non sappiamo qual è il
fattore protettivo ci sono gli anticorpi
specifici
se sono il buio le cellule del cellulare
o se sono altri fattori che ancora non
abbiamo individuato e che serviranno a
esser a individuare quali sono i
parametri sulla cui base per esempio
capire se un vaccino sara protettive o
meno quindi ci aspetta una stagione una
stagione estiva nella quale io penso che
pochi di loro riusciranno ad andare in
vacanza perché dovremmo ancora studiare
lavorare e c'è molto ancora da fare